hi everyone welcome and thank you so
much for coming to hear me talk about
how your companies can contribute back
to the open source projects that you use
this is such an important thing to be
doing and so few companies are really
keeping it as as a high priority and so
I my hope is that you all will take some
of this back with you and we'll get even
more support for the maintainer Xand
creators of these amazing packages that
we use every day my name is Danny Gillis
I'm a software engineer and I work
specifically on in deeds open source
team in our program office I'm a tools
engineer I build tools we say that
indeed we help people get jobs and I
like to say that I help the people who
help people get jobs contribute to open
source in my past lives before this I'm
one of those career changers so I was
out of college and AmeriCorps member
doing nonprofit work from there I went
on to be a backpacking trip leader and
an outdoor educator after that I fell in
love with the Bay Area and I decided I
needed to live there and to do that I
needed to learn to code because there
was very a few other ways to make enough
to live there so I started on that path
along the way I taught kids to code to
get my syntax down better and then I
taught adults the code through UC
Berkeley's extensions coding boot camps
and now I'm at indeed and I'm super
happy to be there especially in an
open-source program office as you can
tell I'm a bit of a do-gooder so of
course I ended up in open-source so this
is what we're going to be talking about
today what is a NOS po stands for open
source program office
what is your AA spa's purpose so I'm
actually curious can I see a show of
hands for people who are at a company
that already has an open-source program
office cool a few of you do wonderful
how many are at a company that doesn't
have an official Osmo but there are
still some initiatives around
contributing back to open source awesome
and probably the rest of the people in
the room but let me just check how many
of you are here because your company
doesn't do this and
you really want them to great that gives
me an idea of which things to focus on
so this will be what is your current
auspice purpose what should it be or as
you help to maybe make something start a
small one or a big one what do you want
it to be how to convince your leadership
team that they should be doing this and
then once you've convinced them how you
actually can contribute back to those
projects and some resources at the end
extra ones okay so an open source
program office is kind of like that's
kind of the nuclear option that would be
the best way to support open sources to
have a dedicated team with engineers
with legal with a head of the
open-source program office as well as a
community manager maybe a project
manager in there that's the ideal way
but whatever your company's level is
that you can start as simple as just
doing one event you can also do
something in between I know some
companies will have things like an
open-source guild so you can just find
some other people who agree with you and
get together once in a while and talk
about how how you can work on these
goals these are some of the things that
an auspi can do one is if your coworkers
are already have projects they've been
working on they want to open-source them
and ausco can help them figure out how
to do it correctly without making a ton
of mistakes you can also support your
existing open source projects if there
wasn't an das Poe maybe people didn't do
things super well so you might have kind
of some legacy code in the way that they
were open sourced and it can be really
helpful to actually get some guidance
also supporting the projects that your
company depends on also license
compliance are you using the projects in
accordance with their licenses
especially for bigger companies this is
a great way to convince higher-ups that
they should have an Oslo because you do
not want to get sued for something like
that if you're a high
profile company and also can also help
with signing clas which is a gosh I'm
forgetting that acronym all of a sudden
you know a contributor License Agreement
and some auspices will even review all
contributions before they actually go to
the project just to make sure that no
one has left in any identifying
information or things like that and also
Community Development both internal
within the company as well as external
for any open source projects that you
have so I mentioned that I did an
AmeriCorps year of service at this point
it was so many years ago but I learned a
few things that I think are really
relevant to small open source programs
because nonprofits are similarly often
small and kind of wily and working with
whatever they have so one of the things
that I learned is about a concept called
resource mapping this is basically where
you go into in the case of AmeriCorps a
neighborhood or in this case your
company and you look around and you
don't say well what do we not have what
what what do we wish we had but you see
what do we have maybe it's a whole bunch
of really passionate engineers maybe
it's some really passionate technical
documentation people maybe it's the one
legal person who's like I know all about
open source legal stuff maybe it's just
you don't have anything except for you
and one member of the senior leadership
team who's like yes I care about this
and maybe you have some open rooms
available in your company so you haven't
grown to fit the space yet resource
mapping is where you look at everything
you have and you see how it all fits
together so that you can get some stuff
done the other thing that I learned
during my AmeriCorps year is that there
are two types of nonprofits successful
and not successful but what's less
obvious is that I noticed every time the
ones that were successful were the ones
that were very focused and the ones that
were not successful were the ones that
ran all around and tried to do
everything all at once they were clear
on their mission and goals and they
weren't getting distracted by the shiny
new thing that came
so for example if you're a small arts
organization a non-profit and someone's
like oh uh our community needs some
clean as community cleanup and a
neighborhood watch and all of those
things those are not the things that you
should be working on it's confusing to
everyone involved and it strains your
resources on the other hand these are
two nonprofits that I worked with that
did incredibly well at staying focused
and at different sizes including growing
so KC trees their mission is to plant
trees Street trees throughout Washington
DC ton of benefits really important they
work - one way they had an endowment and
that meant that every year they knew how
much money they had because it was the
interest from that endowment was their
operating budget so they had very few
employees all but I think one of them
work directly with volunteers they had a
ton of volunteers we planted trees all
over they brought in an AmeriCorps team
to help them and they were able to do a
little bit of social justice work as
well by planting trees in
under-resourced neighborhoods but only
because that was so specifically they
were still planting trees it was just a
little extra thrown in there
the Center for economic progress was a
nonprofits that had started really tiny
and had grown over the years by the time
we got there they did taxes for
low-income families so they could get
the Earned Income Tax Credit and at
first they had two or three sites where
they would do taxes the next year they
had added a couple more because they'd
learned how to do it the next year they
were like what should we do next oh
maybe we should advertise more and they
focused on that the year after that they
added in bringing some banks in so that
any people who came in who are unbanked
could get bank accounts after that they
started adding in financial literacy and
so on and so forth and that is how an AA
spoke grows incrementally based on the
resources that you have so you want to
be very clear on what your mission is
perhaps your mission is that you want to
be open sourcing some of the code that
your co-workers have written they're
really excited if that's your mission
then I do want to tell
a little bit about some mistakes to
avoid when you're open sourcing I got
these from a talk that my grandpa's Jack
Humphrey gave he's one of our VPS of
engineering and he made some of these
mistakes and indeed when he opened
sourced our our first round of projects
and since then he has created a nostos
that we don't make them again the first
one is don't just code in secret if it's
going to be an open-source project
started out open-source that way you can
get maybe some people excited maybe you
can get in the community started it's a
lot easier to stay open once you're open
similarly don't do an internal fork that
is going to be the death knell of your
project whether it's at the beginning or
in the middle don't think oh I'll have
the internal fork that we use but we'll
keep the open source one updated it
doesn't happen over and over again I've
seen it doesn't happen so don't do that
another one is not getting any publicity
if you are going to open source a
project hopefully there's a market for
it and that one's number four see if
people care is there already a consensus
that everyone's using another tool that
does the thing if so maybe don't open
source it but if not get some publicity
going get some buzz get a community
maybe you know go on on one on one and
get some people who are excited and grow
from there it doesn't make any sense to
open source something and not tell
anyone and the last one is not
maintaining your project if you open
source something you were making a
commitment that you are going to pay
attention to issues you're going to get
back to people within a timely manner
you will pull in any contributions that
are made that makes sense things like
that so those are what to avoid if you
want to be caring about your company's
open source projects for the rest of the
talk I'm going to be talking more about
how your company can contribute to other
projects the ones that you use in deeds
mission indeed sauce pose mission is to
build a culture of widespread active and
recurring open source participation and
specifically contributing back to the
projects that
we use as Daniel Compton said yesterday
I know how many of you were at that talk
it was wonderful it should be a
partnership between the creator and the
user and not one that's based on this
for that but just working together and
building something that we all can use
there we go
once you have your mission you'll need
to get a figure out what your goals are
maybe you'll want one two or three in
the beginning these are just six not
random ones but what I want you to do in
the very beginning is actually
brainstorm all of the things that you
might possibly need to do in order to
reach that goal
because then you can actually order them
and figure out what what makes sense
because it's not necessarily that most
important thing that you want to do
first actually what you want to start
with is anything that might be a blocker
in the future this will save you a lot
of time in the long run maybe you are
building something based off of an open
source project that's not inside of your
company and so you're going to want to
start talking to those people right away
maybe it's even a project inside of your
company maybe you'll need permissions
for something start doing that right
away make sure you're getting buy-in
from the senior leadership team from
managers things like that do that right
away
other interfacing with departments like
legal maybe marketing if you care about
having a sub-brand we have a really cool
aquatic sub brand that's fun and we
think about it in terms of caring about
the ecosystem of the ocean like we care
about the ecosystem of open source and
it just sort of keeps that in mind for
us another one that you'll want to start
right away is hiring if you're lucky
enough to have so much buy-in that you
have a budget for a team as we all know
hiring is hard especially for
engineering right now so start that one
right away
it took Dwayne O'Brien our head of open
source almost a year from when he
started to get me on the team and I was
the fur
to engineer and I was an intern and so I
did some really cool things but it was
took a while before we were even able to
get a more seasoned engineering and cool
stuff all of those once you have those
potential future blockers at least
started then you can start thinking
about okay what's most important what is
the meat of getting my vision to come to
fruition and you can start on that along
with what is the most exciting what are
those easy wins so that you can go to PE
you can go to senior leadership and say
look I got this done you can go to your
co-workers and say isn't this so cool
that this happened don't you want to be
a part of it and also it just gets you
excited as well so how do you get buy-in
it's all about figuring out what why
your company should care about open
sources the sustainability luckily there
are a ton of great reasons I've got like
three slides of these okay so the first
one and I feel like it's one of the most
important is that it helps you avoid
vulnerabilities and the projects that
you use day-to-day this is super
important it's so important that earlier
this year the Linux Foundation actually
created a new open-source fellowship
program it's based off of outreach e
which is another amazing program and
Linux foundations is specifically to get
some people some fellows in working on
open source projects to squash those
bugs and those vulnerabilities to make
sure that we have as few security
concerns as possible if you're in the
code you know what's going on if you're
just mindlessly taking in dependencies
you don't know what's going on and
you're vulnerable another really
important one is maintaing maintainer
burnout
some of these maintainer czar doing it
all alone and if they aren't going to
get any help they'll eventually you
decide some of them will decide that
they don't care anymore
that can lead to abandoned projects
which makes it hard if at some point you
you do need something else from it or if
there are security vulnerabilities that
were found
no one there to even pull in a really
basic change or even malware I don't
know how many of you heard about open
stream the npm project where the
maintainer had stopped paying attention
to his project anymore it was still used
as a dependency in a ton of other NPM
packages and he just sort of deprecated
it but it was there and working and then
someone came along and said hey I would
love to take over your project and
maintain it and the maintainer was a
great take it please
I no one no one wanted to do this I
didn't have the resources I'm over it
and it turned out that that person put
in some malware and some people were
really annoyed with the original
maintainer but like honestly if no one
was paying enough attention to care then
I feel like it's the community's problem
not just that one maintainer another
reason is you really can't increase the
speed and agility of your code by
contributing back as I mentioned Forks
are terrible both for your own projects
but also if you're consuming a project
as you probably know if you fork it then
you have to do a ton of work anytime
anything's updated to bring it back in
and it's so much easier in the long run
even though it seems harder and the
short run in the long run it's so much
easier to actually just make whatever
your changes contribute it back up and
that way everyone can benefit from it
which is really great and then when
things change you're still caught up you
don't have an internal fork that gets
further and further and further from the
main branch so it's really a win-win
which is what I love about open source
in general another part of having
everyone contributing to open source is
that then you start bringing it into
your company as inner source and that's
basically when you take the concepts of
open source and use them within the
company what that does is it creates a
culture of helping each other if I'm on
the job spotter team and I notice a
problem in
in a DevOps tool I can go to them and
say hey do you want me to fix this and
it's if it's considered a part of my job
to do that and that's just an accepted
part of the way that we work then that
helps everybody
another part of inner source is that you
get everyone thinking about using an
existing project before building their
own which can save a lot of time now
granted you don't always want to
sometimes you do need to build your own
thing but take a look first and there
are a lot of people who don't because
it's not a part of the company culture
you might be able to save money on
licenses if you're able to get something
added into the code either because you
add it or because you've been working
with the community and you start talking
to someone and you're like we were
thinking about adding this and they're
like oh I was thinking about adding that
I don't know if anyone would care great
I'll make it happen and then everything
it's better for you it's better for
everyone also talent attraction hiring
is hard but if people know you're doing
good open-source work engineers are more
excited to come work for you
similarly customers goodwill and the
last one is moral responsibility I feel
very strongly that as as companies who
consume these things that make sense for
us to give back so hopefully you'll come
up with a few of those and your senior
leadership team will be like wow those
are great reasons we're in ok cool so
now how can we contribute what do we do
there are three main ways I would say
the three main categories would be money
code and non code contributions so let's
get specific
so as I mentioned if you have a NOS
though you might be able to do a number
of these things if you're just one
person and you want to get people
started thinking about this she was one
of these to do one of my favorites was
first-time contributor events and you
can do them at various levels there will
be some very technical people and for
them maybe they've never contributed to
open source though so you can help them
find their first issue let them know
about tags like good first issue and
help on it and things like that
and if they're not coders but designers
you can help them find where what
projects might need their help during a
first-time contributor event for people
like that it's great if you can actually
have them choose their first thing that
they're going to work on and even get
started on it and a piece of that is
that when you decide to work on it the
first step is actually to respond on the
issue and let everyone know hey I'm
gonna take this and or even it maybe
it's something they found maybe it's a
bug and then the first step would be to
create an issue and say hey this is a
bug I want to I want to work on it and
see what they say for other people they
might not be coders and so they might
not know how to use git and github and
that would be a great thing to teach and
a first-time contributor event study
halls are similar basically we end up
doing a weekly one in San Francisco
because that's where most of my team is
based and it's just time for people to
get together and work on their
contributions incidentally we've noticed
that a lot of our QA engineers are
especially excited about open source
because they want to a lot of them want
to grow from QA engineers into I guess
software engineers and so they see it as
a good stepping stone so we see them at
the study halls also you can bring
employees to open source conferences
it's a great place to table and then
that way you're bringing people together
talking about open source really
building that internal community and I
would recommend bringing legal people to
those conferences to some of the open
source conferences have legal tracks
then it's really nice to have at least
one of your legal team with you knowing
what's going on
one thing I would recommend right away
is October is when October fest starts
how many of you know about hacked over
fest cool it is basically it's a created
by digital ocean anyone can sign up and
if you submit I believe it's five that
might have changed this year pull
request during the month of October then
you get a t-shirt doesn't seem like that
big of a deal we all have 20 million
free t-shirts but oh man incentives do a
ton I went to a talk the other day that
was showing that even when it's not a
physical incentive if it's just like a
little icon next to your name even those
incentives do a huge amount and that's a
good thing to know when you're trying to
incentivize contributions whatever
little things you can do people are into
it and so for a Oktoberfest last year
that was right after I joined we had
just gotten three new members of the
team to supplement Dwayne and we decided
to run a heck tober fest event and so we
had a kickoff party we had slides
throughout the office telling people
about it and we had a closing party and
we sent like small little gifts to
anyone who had contributed oh no wake up
okay
similarly 24 Polar quest is just like
hacked over fest except for the month of
December for that one we decided to send
out holiday cards to anyone who had
contributed during 24 pull requests and
I'm here to show you that you don't need
to be perfect in your execution this was
going to be our holiday card with some
decorations from the office but we just
delete that busy it was December we
didn't send them out right away so they
became Valentine's Day cards
and we sent them to anyone who had
contributed at all since we'd been
monitoring and we were like thank you
for contributing and people loved it as
I mentioned contributions can be more
than just code and in fact if you think
about an open-source project needs all
of the same things that any other
product needs so things like design work
for the project itself for the project's
website even documentation like I just
open-source something for the first time
and
I was like I'm not good at markdown and
making my Doc's look good and
presentable that took me a while to the
point where I thought about bringing a
designer in and then decided that I
wanted to learn that skill but for some
other projects especially with long docs
design it's super necessary in fact
documentation work in general I know
it's said often but until I worked in a
nas Bo I was very hesitant I thought
people wouldn't welcome random changes
especially if they were small I thought
I'm a new engineer if I don't get it
it's because I'm new but it turns out
that hasn't been the case at all if I
don't get it it's guaranteed that other
people don't get it too and people are
constantly so glad that I've contributed
to the docs
I keep getting shoutouts in random
places and it's a great way to like be
like hi I had I did minimal work and
made a huge impact and people get really
excited you can work on tiny grammar
things clarity even tutorials for things
that don't have them yet another piece
is marketing marketing people can get
involved in open source
translations are necessary one of my
teammates is working on some
translations right now even just opening
an issue for something that you see is a
bug is a contribution and we value it
we're commenting on one you can just
like a little yeah me too as long as
you're being nice about it is a way for
the maintainer x' to know oh I should
actually look at that it's affecting a
number of people legal of course and a
way that you can really help maintain
errs to not get burnt out is a website
called code triage comm and it helps you
can you can help maintain errs by
triaging their issues and that's cool
okay so another so that was events and
initiatives fostering a culture of
contribution throughout the company will
also just help in general because then
people are thinking about it more and
more and it becomes normalized so we
have the we have little monitors around
the office I know other people do too
sometimes we call it wonkavision and
we're constantly saying stuff about open
source
but for the fast fun Oktoberfest is
coming up we're having a get-together
whatever we're doing we have a lot of
blog posts and wiki pages with advice on
what to do if you want to contribute to
an open-source project how to get the
CLA signed how to open source go and
project things like that you can also if
that if you're a one-person team doing
this you can find those articles around
the Internet and then just post them
various places yeah and in terms of the
first time contribute contributor
workshops there's a lot of info on how
to run those around the internet even
just having an open-source slack channel
that people can chat in people can ask
questions in if you are a global company
like indeed it's nice to have some
ambassadors at other offices people who
are excited like you and can you know if
you plan a hack tober fest event they
might also run one if they're at their
office comcast is doing something really
cool they started an open-source Fellows
program where people could apply to be a
fellow and work on only open source for
at the time they did is a 20% program
they've decided to switch it up to ten
weeks instead so the person can really
focus and it's great because that person
or people get to work on open source
projects that they're passionate about
and they're choosing a lot of won a lot
of projects that will help them to not
have to be on licenses anymore because
they're like oh well this project if we
can just add these few things to it we
can use in then we won't need to use
this other license thing that we're
paying for so that's another were like
just great win win one and getting
manager buy-in for the concept that
doing this work is your work and it
should be counted in employee reviews
that's one of the big tasks that we've
been tackling over the last few quarters
because quarterly reviews are a big part
of our culture and so we built some
contributor dashboards that employees
can use to
so what they've been doing anyone who
gives us their github ID we look at
their contributions and make a dashboard
it has a bunch of different insights
this is just a piece of it and you can
see how like it says what repo you were
in and what kind of event it was and by
doing that you can start that
conversation with your boss and be like
you can see what I did another way that
you can contribute is of course money
and money should come with no strings
attached Daniel was talking about this a
lot in his talk yesterday patronage is
great and all but not if you're saying
oh well you have to build what we want
let them let them do their thing we're
here to help each other as a partnership
so there are a lot of new things that
are popping up for this it's very
exciting
github sponsors is pretty much brand new
you can if you go to a repo they'll have
a contributing MD if they're I guess
enrolled in the sponsors program and
that's one way you can give money open
collective is another group you can go
to their website and it will have a
bunch of projects in there and show how
to give them money some projects just
even use patreon especially if they're
small another thing that your company
can do is hire an OS maintainer and
specifically just let them work on the
thing that they were working on that is
a great way to just let add to the
ecosystem other things I only learned
about closure together and Ruby together
yesterday and they're kind of groups
that a Pete of organizations that come
together and decide together aware to
give money and tide lifts is a new
initiative where it's a it's actually a
company and they've talked to a bunch of
maintainer and they've gather everyone
together and then they go to like let's
say and deed would come to them and say
hey we want to support the open-source
projects we use and they'd be like great
they run their dependency analyzer tell
you what your dependencies are and you
pay the money and they give that money
on to the open source projects that are
your depend
seize it indeed we've decided to do an
initiative called the Foss fund that
we're super excited about and I want to
tell you a tiny bit about it essentially
it is a way of democratizing the
contribution process across indeed every
month we give $10,000 to an open-source
project
and we let in ddn's any indeed Ian can
nominate any project and we have them
tell us why and then when it comes time
for voting anyone who has contributed to
open-source in any way that month is
allowed to vote and we we tell that we
show them the reasons why people
nominated them and we've been doing it
for about six months and it's been very
successful we're really excited about it
we're hoping that other people might
also want to start phospho it doesn't
have to be ten thousand even a thousand
dollars a month five hundred a month
anything really helps out especially the
smaller projects so these are just some
places you can learn more about what the
Foss Fund is if you're interested when
we be totally happy to help mentor you
or help you figure out how to do it we
also open sourced
I made a tool that allows me to see
which indeed Ian's
whose github IDs we have contributed
that month and it's called starfish and
that allows you to super easily run a
your own Foss fund if you want to we
also have a form that people can fill
out if their contributions aren't on
github of course not all contributions
are it just turns out that some really
large percentage are so the easiest way
the biggest bang for the buck because as
I said I suppose like nonprofits are
small the easiest way was just to do
github and let people tell us other
things all right so you've got some
buy-in you're doing cool things how do
you keep that buy-in you might need to
measure your success so you want to
think about actually let me go back you
want to think about what questions will
really tell me how I'm doing on my goals
and what metrics do I need to gather to
be able to answer those questions
if you choose the right metrics not only
will help you answer those questions it
will also tell you what's working and
what's not maybe you can see if I ran
that first time a contributor workshop
did it get more contributors you
sometimes will even from the data you
gather come up with new initiatives just
by the information that you've got and
we don't measure lines of code we try
not to measure contribution counts it's
a part of what we gather because it's an
easy you know and you're gathering them
of course it's easy to tally them up but
we don't really weird it we don't say oh
you are the highest contributor we like
you best what we care more about is
people who are new contributors and
people who are recurring contributors we
also don't have a scoreboard like we
know there's no where there's nowhere
that we put up and say hey employees
look at who's doing the best we care
most about active recurring participants
people who triggered an event that we
care about two or more days over the
course of a quarter in any of the events
that we measure which are these ones so
not just code but also comments and
issues and such we're not doing push
events because generally those are the
personal projects and it's also just not
good open source hygiene I love this
xkcd and so I thought about it when I
was deciding what tools to use to do
these contribution measuring there are a
ton of tools out there they mostly look
all by default at an open-source repo
and the contributions around it in the
health of that repo because until
recently companies were really only
worried about their own open source
projects I've been seeing that shift a
bit over the course of last year which
was really exciting so what we did at
first I started with starfish actually
came out of me doing a really basic
crawl github for for user events and
send it to me and if you just want
something quick and basic you can take
starfish and switch it up really easily
to do that and I can help you if you if
you
need that but it wasn't robust in the
long run so we're using something called
github crawler it's a Microsoft project
so it's on github as Microsoft /gh
crawler gah - crawler and we added some
code to be able to crawl user events and
that contribution we'll be in in another
week or two so up streams once you
decided what metrics you're going to
gather you're gonna need a baseline
quarter so do what we do don't do it we
did don't get the baseline quarter the
same quarter that you're doing all the
new exciting things because then you're
gonna get a really high number of
contributions or whatever it is you're
measuring and then the next quarter
you'll be like oh oops
it just went down because we're not like
doing all the everything and it's not
brand new all at once
turns out Google is a really easy way to
get some basic things the the Google
Forms if you already use the Google
suite within the company will give you
people's LDAP when they fill things out
that's how we gather github IDs when I
put the basic contribution info the
numbers into a spreadsheet it does
graphs which I hadn't known
it's normally really expensive to find
out social media mentions so we set up a
Google News Alert for whenever people
mentioned indeed open source not amazing
but it's quick easy cheap there are also
a lot of useful numbers that you might
not even have realized that you wanted
but you get for free just because you're
doing things I call them the like free
meal deal so de metrics you you buy the
meal and you just get the soda for free
things like you have a slack channel so
check and see how many members you have
and see what how that is trending unique
views on wiki pages participants in the
events that you're excited about and
this year we're excited to see how the
numbers change if you have physical live
workshops and things numbers of
attendees Duane also likes to talk about
potato metrics which is basically
there's a thing you want to measure
but it would be really hard to measure
it so how can you measure something
related like if you want to know how
many french fries you're selling you can
basically tell just by looking at how
many potatoes you use that's a potato
metric later on you might change from
the super outdated POS system to a nice
new shiny one that can actually tell you
how many fries you've sold and that's
great you can update your tooling later
but to begin with you can use a potato
metric okay so how much data should you
gather at first Ethan be like Pac Man
gather up everything go for that little
like cherry that's floating around a log
because it's there anyway on your path
don't go out of the way for it but like
if it's there you're like great I got
the cherry that's awesome and you might
be able to see some cool things based on
all of those that data that you're
gathering that you didn't even know you
wanted um but then once you've done that
and you've gotten a good baseline I
really encourage you to stop gathering
all to everything because as we all know
now metadata is actually super powerful
and right now you know who's in charge
of the data it's you you're great but
what about three years down the line
what about five years down the line what
my leadership decide they care about
later what might they do with those
metrics you never know
so don't grab there anything you don't
need and some other resources I want to
tell you about almost done
one is the to do group they're wonderful
they're a group of companies that have
auspice or baby ah spas that work
together comps to collaborating on best
practices sharing tools and training
materials there's more than 40
organizations involved now it's in the
Linux Foundation now highly recommended
go to the website and look up all the
various guides if you're interested the
Kaos community is there if you're really
interested in metrics and community
health they're also super nice everyone
involved in open source was really nice
that's one of the best ways to reasons
to get involved related to that we made
this slide super at the last minute
and I just wanted to dedicate this talk
to my friend Dan who died in the
conception diving boat accident a few
weeks ago he was co-creator and Co
maintainer of fast LED which allows you
to address all sorts of LEDs make
gorgeous art there's amazing things
online and he just kind of epitomized
the generosity of the open source
community and the way that it's so it's
all about the win-win it's all about
working together to build something
beautiful that everyone can use and
because of that let me know if you'd
like to talk more about any of these
things we're always happy to help anyone
in the do group is happy to help as well
and yeah thank you so much for coming
[Applause]